let's do a couple of quick Trump updates
here at the end of the show much to the
pleasure of many and dismay of others
Trump increasingly having a smaller and
smaller role on this show and in
American politics and uh I think that
that's a great thing to the extent that
uh he's horrible and dangerous for
American democracy let's start report
from best Levin of the
um a Vanity Fair Trump has been
hibernating at home for almost a month
yes Trump has barely left his house
since announcing that he's running for
president in 2024. after a less than
rapturous response to his 2024 campaign
announcement the ex-president has barely
left the grounds of Mar-A-Lago something
is going on here something is going on
um Bess Levin writes about Trump's
preparation to announce the bid for
office and the assumption that this
would start a two-year period in which
he would befetted the world over
everywhere he went people would
spontaneously break into song and dance
thanking their favorite President for
stepping up to rescue the country
it has not really happened that way
Trump has not really been interviewed on
any prominent media since announcing hey
I'm a former president and I'm running
again that's normally would be pretty
big news and as best Levin writes in
reality things didn't entirely pan out
that way almost no one in the Republican
party has come out to support Trump
despite threats to punish Republicans
who don't endorse him Rupert Murdoch's
media Empire has spent considerable time
and effort telling people he's a loser
and a new Yahoo news you gov poll
released Thursday has Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis beating Trump by Five
Points
DeSantis hasn't even announced that he's
running remember instead of 24 7 parades
he was hit with a guilty conviction for
his family business which a jury said
committed 17 different crimes and Ivanka
made clear she wants nothing to do with
Trump's future endeavors so the point
here is Trump's really not leaving his
house he's essentially not leaving the
Washington Post writes Trump's seclusion
within the ornate walls I call them
gaudy you can call them ornate I would
call them gaudy walls Trump's seclusion
within the ornate walls of his club and
a series of controversies from dinner
with anti-semitea and Nick Fuentes
through a social media post suggesting
the termination of Constitution have
left him isolated within his own party
as he tries to mount a political
comeback
Herschel Walker's loss on Tuesday is the
latest blow prompting more Republicans
to join the chorus faulting him for
dragging down the party's performance in
this year's midterms the former
president presents our biggest risk of
losing for 2024 and conservatives are
tired of losing said Bob vanderplatz
head of the family leader a social
conservative group so bottom line
Trump's barely leaving his house and it
seems as though things are not going
particularly well there's one really
funny thing about this now let's let's
talk about the political implications
first we're two years away just under
two years away I guess we're 23 months
away if we want to make a more accurate
countdown from the 2024 election
it's too early to say there's no
momentum and this is going to fail we
don't we just don't know that at this
point in time we need to wait and see if
Trump mounts some momentum this is far
earlier then typically people announce
that they are running but we've already
seen
at least one very good article making
the case that Trump may not even make it
to the first Republican primaries which
I believe I I believe it's Iowa uh I
believe a Taiwan both sides and that if
he doesn't get momentum going at some
point in time he may just drop out
rather than lose now someone like
Michael Cohen all along argued Trump
wouldn't run Trump's running but is he
really running in the sense that if you
announce and then you never leave your
house and then you just slowly and
quietly go away
did you really run maybe not that's
maybe more of a semantic discussion the
really funny thing is that in the run-up
to the 2020 election Trump and Maga and
the Q wing of the party spent the entire
time slamming President Joe Biden then
candidate Joe Biden for hiding in his
basement and not campaigning now there
was a pandemic at the time you may
recall and he still won and and as I've
said before the really humiliating thing
isn't that Biden was in his basement
it's that if Biden was in his basement
Trump lost by a lot to a guy who was in
his basement but now as the table seemed
to turn it's Trump who is just hanging
out out at home and wishing people
getting married at Mar-A-Lago well and
this sort of thing uh I don't really
know how Trump turns this thing around
and what I mean by that is he can hold
rallies but there's no rallies for other
candidates right now because there's no
other elections the midterm is over so
would a random Trump rally in January of
2023 when you're running for something
in 2024 is that going to get attention
or is it going to seem just kind of
pathetic I don't know that's one option
number two who is going to go and kiss
the ring at Mar-A-Lago when it's not
clear that Trump actually maintains the
political cachet that people would in
the Republican Party would feel the need
to do that yes Kerry lake is sucking up
to Trump because she wants to be his VP
yeah Marjorie Taylor green is sucking up
to Trump because she wants to be his VP
but the people and then you've got
people like Mitt Romney who have said
not voting for him no matter what but
it's very clear that the vast majority
of Republicans at this point are taking
a kind of wait and see approach which is
we're not going to get behind him until
we see how much power He commands and at
this point it's not very clear because
he's losing in the polls to people who
haven't even announced namely Rhonda
sandis so we're going to follow it but
this is increasingly a guy who looks
like he's out of options and for now
he's staying at home the one thing he is
doing is he's posting to truth social
truth essential and I want to talk about
that next before you go if you enjoyed
this video and want to see more more
please make sure to subscribe to my
YouTube channel you can click the
Subscribe button below or above or
wherever it is on your screen and if you
want to support my work even more
strongly the best way is to get a
membership at joinpakman.com And
subscribe to the podcast for the David
packman show there you can check out
interviews longer clips and much more
it's on all the big podcasting platforms
just search for the David packman show
and all the links are also Down Below in
the video description